kamal 2007.
classical style again d5 as we discussed
before is a
bit of an inaccuracy although
g6 is an ingenious try
don't think i've ever seen this actually
okay let me go knight f3 i don't want to
go knight c3 obviously because then
knight d5 is a normal grenfell
but i feel like this check is a little
bit
annoying to meet because bishop d7 queen
b3 was happening
and here i do not feel that he gets
enough compensation
for a pawn
a little bit of compensation but not
enough
this pin is not dangerous
knight d4 i break the pin with queen d4
no problems no problems there
e5 e5 is a good move
but i think i'm just going to take it
just for fun i'm just going to bring the
queen to h4 here
and if he takes an f3 take with the
bishop
and although my
development is a little bit
behind here i don't think it's going to
matter i think i'm still a pretty sound
pawn up
d5 was a very good move that he played
that has to be has to be said quite
ingenious
knight c6 a logical try
keeping the pieces on the board when
your material down
okay rook d1 i guess developing my
pieces bishop d2
it's all good rook c1
and thus development
was completed
[Music]
should i do okay let me just
once development is completed you can
create some air
for your king now we proceed
to try and exchange some pieces in this
case in this case the rocks
and the u the bishops are usually quite
well placed on
on e1 or e8 and these sort of
of structures you just tuck them away
put the rooks in the center
and the bishop can be active on c3 or b4
later on
and for the moment you just need them
not to
to be in the way of your of your other
pieces
okay let's swing the queen over
i wanted to go knight d4 but i was a
little bit bothered by knight f5 there
exchanging exchanging that nice central
knight so
now after queen a4 i want to go knight
d4 next
yeah let's just
put the knight on a good square
bishop d7 attacking the queen i just go
queen b3
and i'm happy very happy
rook d6 this feels
to me to be too much on the artificial
side
gonna go queen knight e4
obviously 96 was good there as well but
then you can go knight c3
bishop c3 rook e6 and please he's
somewhat keeping his structure
intact you can go bishop
d7 here but i don't think that would
have helped because of
um yeah for many reasons but
mostly because of uh
of uh queen a3 and i think his work is
somewhat trapped he has to go rook b6
and then bishop a5
actually traps it so that would have
put him in a world of hurt as well i
think his plan here is to go b4 but
i got a number of number of good options
then i think i think the simplest of
them just being
taking it if queen before queen before
knight b4 i got 96 winning a full
exchange
if night before i would have had knight
d6 queen d6 knight e6 he has to take
with the queen then i go
queen b4 um once again with the full
exchange
and uh here is just um
all over it to be fair i win i win a
night
and it's um
yeah it's very difficult he resigned
not a bad game by any by any means
just a tough start there with uh with a
pawn down but he made a number of good
moves
after that so so well done